the program and do not necessarily
reflect the views and opinions of eight
news now or next our media group
quite chilling as well the defendant's
dna is alleged to have been recovered
from the hands of
the victim
tonight on politics now a journalist
murdered an elected official charged
with the crime we have team coverage as
the 8 news now investigators break down
the case against the county public
administrator robert tellis plus
senate campaigns dial up the attacks
republican adam laxalt goes after
incumbent democrat catherine cortez
masto on energy she fires back on
abortion plus a declining lake mead will
be the main topic during a lobbying trip
to washington dc next week the
connection between our water and our
business
from eight news now
this is politics now
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler we start
at the intersection of politics
journalism and violent crime right now
clark county public administrator robert
tellis is in jail he is accused of
murdering long-time las vegas review
journal investigative reporter jeff
gehrman who wrote a series of articles
critical of telus and his office the 8
news now investigators have the latest
evidence in the case we start our
coverage with vanessa murphy at telus's
first court appearance
a judge pointing to evidence in this
case like dna
how investigative journalist jeff
gearman appears to have fought for his
life and how it appears robert tellis
waited for him before the attack quite
chilling as well the defendant's dna is
alleged i've been recovered from the
hands of
the victim clark county public
administrator robert tellis is being
held without bail as he faces an open
murder charge the victim long time
review journal investigative journalist
jeff gearman who exposed problems under
the leadership of telus in court
wednesday las vegas justice court judge
alana lee graham noting his shoes hat
and vehicle matching video from the
crime scene his cell phone activity
terminated before during and after the
murder and defensive wounds found on
german no comment from telus when we
tried to talk to him wednesday after he
was questioned by police did you commit
this murder
did you do this tell us anything a
couple of hours later when police tried
arresting tell us he refused to come out
which led to a neighborhood lockdown
clark county district attorney steve
wolfson says police needed a solid case
and dna results were a key part was
there any way he could be kept with
police to avoid that barricade not under
the law
there are rules and laws in place which
say that a person can be detained for a
certain period of time this was a very
fluid dynamic
a few hours a public defender tells me
telus is hiring a private attorney his
next court date is set for tuesday
reporting at the regional justice center
in downtown las vegas vanessa murphy 8
news now again telus is an elected
official and he's keeping his job for
now however if he bails out of jail he
is banned from government buildings the
public administrator's office has been
closed most of the week it was closed
most of the week in a statement clark
county said the decision was made to no
longer have staff in the public
administrator's office report to mr
telus and this solution will be in place
until the public elects a new public
administrator in november clark county
continues to cooperate with metro police
on this active investigation
telus will not win in november he lost
the democratic primary earlier in the
summer telus was defeated by the number
two position in person rather in the
public administrator's office reader
read she's facing off against republican
patsy brown in the general election her
campaign manager told us that this
murder has everyone including brown on
alert
the concern of personal safety
and i know that's something that a lot
of the employees of the public
administrator's office
um even the candidates who are also
seeking office for public administrator
that's something that is going to
resonate and be at the forefront of
their mind
we reported last week brown was arrested
for driving under the influence her
campaign team said she's been mourning
her own father's loss and had an
interview set up with gearman next week
a nonpartisan candidate tabitha al
dabaga is also on the ballot
jeff gehrman's family released a
statement
this week it reads in part as you see on
your screen jeff was committed to
seeking justice for others and would
appreciate the hard work by local police
and journalists in pursuing his killer
we look forward to seeing justice done
in this case we also want to thank
everyone for the outpouring of love
support and recognition for jeff and his
life's work you can find the full
statement from his family and clark
county at eightnewsnow.com
cameron's murder was immediately a high
profile case for metro police thursday
clark county sheriff joe lombardo and
detectives zeroed in on how they found
the suspect we have 8 news now
investigator david charns here to tell
us more about that part of the story
david yeah so right now 45 year old
robert ellis is in the clark county
detention center on that murder charge
and as the investigators first reported
this week it was dna that they found
under jeff german's fingernails that
matched a sample taken from ram telus
early wednesday morning
every murder is tragic
but the killing of a journalist is
particularly troublesome
clark county sheriff joe lombardo and
las vegas metro police investigators say
45-year-old robert tellis quickly became
a suspect in 69 year old jeff gearman's
murder we knew that as investigative
reporter he had written several articles
and there were different allegations and
statements about potential people that
would be upset about it german had
published several articles about
harassment and a possible affair in the
public administrator's office detectives
now say this video is telus walking to
german's home on friday september 2nd
sources say telus is accused of stabbing
german seven times in his neck and torso
video then showed this car later
determined to be registered in telus's
wife's name parking in front of
gaiermann's home after the murder we
ultimately developed video evidence that
showed that that vehicle the gmc denali
parked in front of telus's home had
departed around 9 00 a.m in the morning
on the day of the murder and it returned
around 12 p.m just after the murder
which matched our timeline it wasn't
until a day later saturday that a
neighbor found german's body in a side
yard he was consensually interviewed
voluntarily interviewed
he had the opportunity to obtain an
attorney
he chose not to and subsequent the
termination of the interview he was let
go at that time did you do this did you
commit this murder later in the
afternoon telus returned home that
prompted a two-hour standoff with swat
called in sources saying inside telus
harmed himself and may have attempted to
take narcotics so is there going to be
any look at not releasing a potential
murder suspect back to his home like
that we have a very professional and
effective way of how we safely take
people into custody in these types of
very dynamic situations and that was
proven yesterday something could have
happened in that two-hour window we
wanted to provide a medical attention
which we were successful in doing so and
then we also wanted to make sure that we
were consulting with our district
attorney's office and ensuring a solid
uh case to keep building evidence and
that's what we did successfully thank
you
working to get information exactly what
that law is so the captain they're also
telling me it appears german was working
on even more stories involving telus it
also appears from what we have seen the
past couple days that german's own
reporting may have actually helped
police john now find his alleged killer
because he basically made himself his
own suspect and certainly we've seen on
tell us his social media pages in
hindsight all of the tweets that he
wrote uh against the reporting by by
jeff german uh
after hit the stories aired in the
review journal let's talk about what uh
mr telus is was elected to do run the
public administrator's office what does
exactly the clark county public
administrator do well i think a lot of
us didn't even know that this position
was an elected position you know one of
about 12 to 16 elected positions here in
clark county so basically what the
public administrator is is that is the
office it's about eight people including
uh the head that handle probate so if
somebody dies and uh
they don't have family there to be able
to take over their estate they will come
in and they will basically hold on to
those assets until someone else can or
they will take over if their family
can't administer their state and it's
one of the smallest offices in eight
people in clark county but still that
office was the source of so many of jeff
german's recent stories in the las vegas
review journal let's talk about what was
included in his reporting yeah so a
couple things there he called the office
uh an office in turmoil and he had
played video taken of telus that was in
a car with a female employee others
alleging from that video was an hour
that they were sitting in that car that
this was an inappropriate relationship
telus and that woman told gaiermann that
they were quote hugging in the car the
other stories involved employees who
said there was a culture of bullying and
favoritism in the office there was
enough that the county actually decided
to bring in former coroner county
coroner michael murphy to try to tackle
what was going on there it seems to sort
of be the old
cohort verse new people who tell us had
brought it and obviously there were
concerns raised be the reporting
referenced a complaint filed with clark
county and as we were just saying uh the
staff were told essentially don't have
to deal with mr telus even before all
this went down right and we're working
to get more information and hopefully in
the next couple weeks more will come to
light david thank you very much thanks
john other political news this week
nevada senator jackie rosen has been
diagnosed with coronavirus her office
says she has mild symptoms she's
vaccinated and fully boosted senator
rosen right now is working remotely
while she waits for a negative test
next on politics now campaigns going
strong what republican senate candidate
adam laxalt had to say about energy
policy during a visit with former energy
secretary rick perry and democrats
continuing to hit republicans on the
abortion issue we'll tell you what
senator cortez masto was saying about
black salt's history
local
now welcome back to politics now
former energy secretary rick perry
visited las vegas this week he supported
republican senate candidate senate
candidate adam laxalt it came as las
vegas and california were asking people
to conserve energy during our heat wave
the event was held at rebel oil and gas
the pair criticized president biden for
using federal gas reserves to lower
prices a few cents they called it an
election year band-aid
for them to implement a series of
policies
to drive prices up the way they did
and then to use the reserve for
political purposes to drive these down
and by the way the timing is such that
you know it's going to go right up till
the election that they're tapping into
the strategic reserves it's dangerous
their policies put us in this position
once again reporters at the lax salt
event as has been commonplace were not
allowed to ask questions the cortez
masto campaign criticized perry for
being a fan of the yucca mountain
nuclear waste dump laxalt pointed to his
suing to stop it when he was nevada
attorney general meanwhile incumbent
democrat senator senator catherine
cortez masto she campaigned on a
familiar theme this week access to
abortion she and other democrats held an
event criticizing laxalt's positions on
that issue afl
executive secretary susie martinez said
in the past laxalt worked to prevent
those procedures
when he was attorney general he did
everything that he could to restrict
abortion access
signing on to abortion restrictions
across the country that would allow
states to ban abortion without
exceptions for rape and for incest
laxalt accused her the senator of trying
to change the subject and not focusing
on high gas prices this week governor
steve silac attacked his republican
opponent on abortion
new ads say sheriff joe lombardo the
republican who's running for governor
sponsored a gala for the group nevada
right to life those ads also say that mr
lombardo has an endorsement from the
national group lombardo has acknowledged
nevada law would prevent him from
passing any type of ban on abortion
before 24 weeks
meanwhile this week lombardo laid out
his education policy it called for a
reinstituting of several measures put in
place by former governor brian sandoval
only to be repealed by democrats
sandoval as you remember was a
republican that includes school choice
or education savings accounts esa's
another ready by three it holds students
back in class if they can't read by
third grade which studies show is really
a pivotal point
lombardo also wants to revoke a bill
from the 2021 legislature that cut back
the number of students expelled for
violence in schools
next week the las vegas chamber the
vegas chamber as it's called is going to
its annual lobbying trip in washington
d.c
this trip has some new topics on the
agenda like water and old ones like
interstate highways i spoke with ceo
mary beth seawald
there has never been a more important
time
and never been
more need for nevada to have its voice
heard on capitol hill so the vegas
chamber is taking the largest delegation
ever to washington dc we have more than
200 people going and it's really an
opportunity just for all of us to not
only talk with our local nevada
delegation but also congressional
members from across the country and to
build camaraderie among the business
community here what are some of the big
issues we've talked about so many times
with the business community in las vegas
that you think lawmakers in washington
need to know about well there are
several
not the least of which is water we've
been talking a lot about water lately
conservation you know there are seven
states uh in the colorado river
commission that are impacted the water
it not only provides water to millions
of households across the west but also
hydro power hydroelectric power and so
forth and so that's a topic that we
really need to discuss with our nevada
congressional delegation and really
explain to them not that they don't
already know but it really
gives us a louder voice when we have so
many people to talk about how water
truly impacts not only our daily lives
but economic development how does it
affect economic development when if
you're a business that's looking for to
to set up shop somewhere maybe you've
been someplace else or starting from
scratch
the impact of water has to play into the
decisions that are made the relationship
with the chamber and whether las vegas
even looks appealing to that potential
business creator absolutely water is
definitely a factor as businesses are
looking to relocate here to southern
nevada we we have to face it we are in a
drying climate it's not just a drought
it is a drying climate and and that's
okay it's workable but we have to know
how to
what are some of the best solutions and
ways to go about doing business in a
place that is a drying climate there are
obviously things that we can't do that
you would do in a in a wetter climate
another a long time issue for the vegas
ship that you and i have talked about
many times i-11
i-15 as well but especially i-11 both
interstates are important certainly to
las vegas where do things stand with
trying to increase development increase
funding to try and expand i 11 first and
foremost and maybe widen i-15 absolutely
you know we have gotten to a point
nevada is complete has completed our
portion of i-11
to arizona as you know phoenix and las
vegas are the only two major
metropolitan cities that are not
connected by a major freeway and so
we're working with our friends in
arizona
department of transportation to continue
that project and then for i-15 as you
know you can drive pick a holiday
weekend and it's kind of a parking lot
so
it's really important that we're able
we've been working with the lv cva as
well to to widen i-15 so that's on at
the top of our list as well
and i'll have more with the vegas
chamber next week on good day las vegas
next on politics now though what was in
those documents the latest on the
investigation into classified material
found at mar-a-lago during a raid by the
fbi plus why the aclu is suing the city
of las vegas over festivus this is 8
news
recovery
[Music]
you're watching politics now
[Music]
the nevada aclu is now suing to stop
curfews in downtown las vegas the curfew
from the city of las vegas and fremont
street experience restricts access for
anyone under 21 on weekend nights
fremont street experience right now with
the way they're doing this there's a
special use permit it has it was granted
in july for an event called festivus
that's to justify the curfew well it's
in effect through november but nothing's
really going on our the aclu argues
there is no such event it believes
fremont street is a public square for
first amendment purposes and 18 year
olds should be allowed
the justice department and president
donald trump they have to submit their
choices for an independent party to
review documents seized from mar-a-lago
a month ago the new report that says one
document that was found there at
mar-a-lago is about nuclear intelligence
the washington post also says some
documents found were so closely guarded
that many senior national security
officials didn't have access to them
themselves
a federal judge effectively halted parts
of the justice department's
investigation into former president
trump's handling of classified documents
now the justice department is asking the
judge to change that ruling says it
could do harm to the government and the
public alex limon joining us now from
washington to explain all of this alex
what's the doj's complaint here
well the issue here is that with that
ruling the judge like you said has
effectively halted the doj's
investigation because by ruling that a
special master should be appointed that
means that the doj essentially loses
access to all of the documents that were
seized from mar-a-lago because what has
to happen now is that that special
master needs time to go through all of
the documents and then decide whether
any of them fall under client attorney
privilege and if they do then those are
documents that the doj wouldn't have
access to and so what the doj is arguing
here is that this
time delay you know it could take some
time so many documents were seized it
could jeopardize the entire
investigation and so the doj has gone
back to the judge to ask
for that judge to potentially change
parts of this ruling
the doj says it's conducting a two-part
investigation on this can you tell us
what are those two different parts and
how are they impacted by this ruling
right so the first part of the doj
investigation is directly investigating
whether trump and his team broke any
federal laws by removing these documents
and moving them to mar-a-lago keep in
mind the doj has said many of these
documents are top secret or even
classified and should have never been
taken to mar-a-lago so one is that
aspect of that criminal investigation
the other part of the investigation the
second part is looking into whether u.s
national security was compromised
because these documents were housed
at trump's office at mar-a-lago in it's
a not secure non-government location
there is a concern the doj says that
this could have you know jeopardized
national security if people were walking
in and out of that office we don't know
if any of them you know were possibly
just out you know that is what they are
investigating trying to figure all that
out now the judge has said that the doj
can continue looking into the second
part of that investigation the national
security aspect of it
but the doj here argues that obviously
the two issues are so intertwined the
reason why national security may have
been compromised is because the
documents were moved by trump and his
team that it's pretty hard if not
impossible to continue one part of the
investigation without continuing the
other and so that's why the doj is going
back to ask this judge to potentially
change parts of this ruling um
because they say this is such a
time-sensitive matter as well
interesting stuff alex simone from
washington d.c thank you very much
meanwhile senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell on this issue says he doesn't
have a comment he's been following the
investigation like the rest of us
next on politics now a las vegas man of
the january 6th capitol hill riot is in
federal court next week we'll tell you
what to expect
and i approve this message
this week in what to watch january 6th
please one of the las vegas men involved
ronald sandlin charged in that ride on
capitol hill he's expected to take a
plea deal he has admitted he was there
he's in jail in washington right now
also we're gonna have a longer interview
with republican congressional district
one candidate mark robertson hope for a
debate not going to have that but we'll
have a chat anyway we'll see you next
week
[Music]